welcome to this video playing bingo
bongo FM bingo bongo from Germany hi
from colonia this could be anybody let
alone as I'm probably a bunch of items
2257 hmm and again this line the gmod
this is sam getting really popular i
played it myself a couple of times
reason your video ok i don't know what
the theory i'll let's play let's play a
stupid just and just exchange and let's
see what happens here maybe i can play
them on them on the dark squares here ok
it's very quickly try to get something
going maybe with f5
hmm interesting intending 93 complicated
on c5 I thought f3e but maybe you can
just take the form yeah this is
interesting
of 6mm f3 f6f even look so weird
booya f6 how do i add web counter that
have six
I move like g3 looks like insane
weakening the light squares enormously
okay this weekend that squares as well
but at least it stops the sunday now
yeah well I completely misplayed that F
was super ugly move wow wow okay mmm now
this alone probably deserves to lose the
game okay it's so ugly okay let's see
what is coming up with is probably have
a bunch of good plans need to retreat
this anyway at some point
oh this is actually good news I think I
feared more that more than a set up web
he tries to place the bishop to a five
and three for stuff like that this is
certainly quite okay for black but it
shouldn't be the end of the world
maybe you can really take a funnel take
d3 take F 2 y i can actually but i can
take you six out intermediate means so
it's not really a problem okay so he's
may be able to go to me to create two
very uncomfortable Queenie to a thought
to look at it too hmm it's not nice so
that's some other way to to play that
taking us completely completely bonkers
yeah it's a poem but probably I have
Roxy too and it doesn't even take it
g3 is he going to play gt5 maybe
no this is starting to get okay for me I
think check unless I've overlooking
something simple yeah no it's okay I'm
controlling the file here and not a big
not a big problem
position storm still is quite quite
resilient
of course I'm a bit down on time but
it's quite easy to play time at the end
game
nights coming to f3
check-check
check check check check time check check
check check check well what the
turnaround black resigns yeah I
completely lost threaten from a very
good position ya head completely miss
played the opening even here I know
probably around here black still should
be okay check check this is starting to
get slightly slightly uncomfortable
because this is the new spawn and yeah
nights are tricky they can fork yeah
this is good for what now this is just
week simply he earned ropes but I hide
completely completely miss played the
opening that's a brief look yeah it's
it's starting around here maybe I should
play age 30 I moved to prevent this all
this it's a it's just just a great
active position for black my ideal I've
idea was like saying play here and to
Bishop f4 exchange that and so on but I
never get that form now f6 is a threat
and I don't really know how to prevent
it the computer wants to play this f6
takes takes check it gives Blackledge
understandably blacks got two bishops in
an open position and there's still this
yeah this battery against stage 2 it's
quite annoying I don't have a move I
mean this is what I played and it's a
super hardly move but then I'm i was i
was some more afraid here this is
probably okay no no doubt but this this
i actually liked for me I mean it's the
an unattractive position but it somehow
limits blacks options why why I am block
that the five square I mean there are
ideas maybe at some point go here or I
don't know no no every reason to play a
five if you want to look on the
sixth-ranked with rook f 6 h-6 you can
go here and and try that idea I don't
know yeah black as good in multiple ways
he just lost the weigh-in the time on
scramble alright thanks for watching